hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well your something is
basically first exact tease out you know
calling them all sorts of names you want
to just throw stuff you just wants to
throw a lot of language up and say there
you go he tells him that he has to pay
him you know if he wants to get his
position even though he's eager to give
it and what does he say that that
justice actually is what's the very
first thing you start
yeah but what is he has a particular
catchment yeah and sometimes this is
translated as so whatever is going to be
good for the people who have power well
then he explains himself he says you
know different different societies
different people are in power right if
you have a monarchy the Kings in charge
or the Queen's in charge if you have an
aristocracy it's some sort of ruling
group you know like it could be a
military one top or it could be you know
some sort of elite class you know if
it's a democracy then practically
speaking it's not really the people that
are in charge it's whoever can get the
people to vote for them yes it's the
disciples right wrong that's but then
and what is good or bad so if we're
dealing with justice we're actually
dealing with what's right and wrong
understand
Socrates makes them kind of silly
remarks I mean the wrestler gets to
decide yeah I'm not talking about that
sort of stuff
Socrates brings up a much more important
point where he points out do we always
know what's in our own interest well
let's think about we talked about
children earlier right and parents
telling them hey do what I tell you
because I'm a parent what are some cases
where a child doesn't really know their
own interests yeah yeah I have most kids
are probably you guys scream all day you
know just like a most dogs if you put a
football out there and you just kept
filling it up
they just keep eating it you know some
of them will actually eat until their
stomachs are distended then they laid
out well kids that do that to somebody
don't still do that right not so much
well sometimes more before drinking then
they say the next day I'll never drink
again so you know that would be
something no does the kid want to eat
ice cream yeah if that kid was in charge
if that kid was the king of the Queen
they'd be ordering ice cream to be
brought to them all right now
what are some other cases what about
think about relationships
not wanting to study we're you know the
same thing with music right not wanting
to practice yeah parents well the good
parent will force their child to do some
things that probably the child doesn't
completely enjoy or appreciate now if
you do study a lot then eventually you
come to like study if you do read a lot
eventually kind of like doing scales
even then it's still kinda boring not as
fun as playing a song right one reason
why I don't advance as a banjo player
I'm not advancing if somebody wanted to
make me advance they would have to sit
me down and say okay you're gonna do
this and this and this and that would
actually be to my interest with that it
wouldn't be to what I think is my
interest which is to do whatever I want
to well we can distinguish that's a good
question that'd be a weird kind of
player and that's we want one song all
the time who drive their own nuts but a
banjo has that drone strategy is always
playing the same no matter what what
what Socrates would say would be that I
would be failing to distinguish between
what I feel to be in my interest and
what is genuinely away interest we can
be mistaken about what really is in our
interest he says this goes for rulers
too now think about if you were put in
charge and the temptations that you
taste suddenly you're king of the world
what sort of temptations with you face
where you would he would have desires
all right and you with the K that's in
my interest but it probably would not be
in your long-term interests okay I think
that's a good good example and then
certain laws keep you from doing things
that will make you worse off you know
why do we regulate drugs keeping having
fun you know we had one time they didn't
you know at one time you had all these
half of medicines and a lot of women
were cooked out more basically hooked on
opiates guys would be out there in the
beer garden drinking beer their wives
would be you know somewhere else all
taking nips opiates all day long of
course they found they needed these home
remedies you know because after why they
get hooked down the driveway after a
while I said hey that'll do is a good
idea we shouldn't let people actually
put whatever they wanted to these things
and then we probably shouldn't let
people in there's I mean there's there's
there's a case to be made that certain
drugs may not be as behind
they gave me not to be right now but
some drugs there really shouldn't be any
argument at all
what's the leg hooked on heroin like
like that how about a crystal mouth I
don't know anybody who says oh yeah that
is the ideal that's exactly what the and
there's a lot of people who are doing
maths right
they they have a variety of different
reasons and they would say it's in my
interest I want to do as much method as
possible because I like the way it feels
but then you could you know if they were
reasonable you could point out them this
is not a long-term interest if you're
the ruler man you could do anything you
like you couldn't get indulge in any
sort of drug that you wanted you could
let you could break rules about abusing
people in certain ways what are the
things you're not supposed to do to
other people in our society bad things
yeah you got some rape anybody
right I mean there's there's laws on the
books about that if you if you were put
in power and you really didn't have a
lot of checks on you and you didn't he
have sort of strong the world fibre
established and somebody looks tempting
then maybe you know you force yourself
or you know you arrange things so that
you can make them an offer that they
can't refuse or something along those
lines now what would happen to you as a
person that you would you be becoming
better or worse
what do you
oh yeah yeah within that framework
you're right within that framework yeah
that's the only thing that when its
operating but there are certain like
millou's certain social variants that
seems to be with everybody especially
like in half but right now certain parts
yeah and then you know the child soldier
thing is a good example as well they
take these children and they brutalize
them and now it's been going on like
four or five generations so the people
who did it before we're at one time
themselves taken away from their homes
at ten years old and you know all sorts
of things that would be sort of an
immutable things right now if you had
any qualms oh if you had any sort of
like you know think of the back your
head saying you know maybe this isn't
right you'd already be sort of getting
outside of the white things right there
you would see that it's not fully yeah
yeah there's what Socrates putting up
sometimes the rulers don't actually know
it's in their own interests so if you're
going to define justice or goodness as
doing just what the rulers are
commanding some type of the rulers will
actually command you to do things that
are not good for them so which is it
there's there's a contradiction there
there is some sort of way in which this
argument or this position that through
something as taken goes off the rails